tomorrow is tax day which means if you
have not yet completed your tax return
you're probably working on it right now
the process has not changed much this
year but next year Effects of the
president's tax law will become more
apparent correspondent Peter Doocy tells
us how even though the ink on the tax
reform bill has been dry for four months
the annual mid-april headache millions
of Americans get around the time of the
IRS filing deadline is not going
anywhere yet this is the last time
you're going to fill up that long
complicated horrible return for most
taxpayers tax day 2018 won't be
dramatically different than previous
years because the new law passed towards
the end of tax year 2017 so the new
rules kick in next year next year's
filings will also finally reflect lower
rates fewer brackets and a standard
deduction nearly twice the size of this
year's individuals be able to deduct
more against their taxable income and
they would have previously this may mean
lower tax bills but also it may mean
that a lot of individuals may not have
to itemize their deductions any more
cuts for individuals run through 2025
while corporate cuts are permanent a
problem for Democratic critics the GOP
tax scam was the future of our seniors
and our families and our children in
order to give even more money to Wall
Street
pharmaceutical companies big
corporations and the wealthiest 1%
Republican House Ways and Means
Committee Chairman Kevin Brady writes in
the USA Today while we are in the midst
of this year's frustrating tax season
filing under the old broken tax code
things look bright for next year and
experts say 2019 could be the year some
citizens see their April tax bills
disappear there's a much bigger exempt
amount there's bigger standard
deductions they might have children and
child credits what you'll probably see
next year some people going to file and
thinking away I don't know anything this
is fantastic it would be quite a change
if people are indeed pleased to get a
letter from the IRS and the tax
collector has a long way to go to get
there the acting commissioner says
new language in the new law means
they've got to make changes to four
hundred fifty different sets of forms
Brett all right Peter thank you